FOR THLATESTEVERYTHIAT'S GOING
SOP HAS  INDICTED.
>>S RIGHT, JAK THE PINDICTED CO
INRF THEC
PRAND OVERTURN THE RESUL
T
THHISTORIC.
ALW WE DO NOHAVE THE GE        Y
EXACT COUNT OR CHARGES IN FRONT
WE'RE WAITINR E TO
UNSEALBLY THIS INDICTMENT.
INFORMN
I CAN SORT OF HEAR THEM OVER ML.
IN'RE NGT
EXACTHA CAN
LEN ECIFIC
BUT YES WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
INDICTED IE SPECIACOUNSEL'S ST
EFFORTS TO OVERTURE 2020
ELECTION VERY MUCH EXPECTED.
RECENT WNFORMING THAME HCOULD VA
HEECTO APPEAR BEFORE
.
AND HIS LAWYERS MET WITH
S TEAM LATE
EXPECT THEY
COULD ST ATHEY IT.
IT APPEARS THEY WE
JAKE?
>> SO WE HAVE THE DI
HERE.
E, CONSPIRACTORA
THE UNITED STATES.
TWO, CONSPIRACY TO PROCEEDING.
COUNT  OBSTRUCTION
EEDING.CIAL
D FOURRACYT
EVAN PEREZEL ABOUT
IS FR T OFDONALD>> T ONES N REPS
TARGET LETTER.
HA WT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HADED
BRING THDIIS NOW OUT IPUBLIC.
TH FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
AND THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ANNOUNCED IT NOW.
L TRYING T
THIS.
BUOBVIOUSLY, T CONSPIRACY TO
E UN S
TGE
VERY RARELBROUGH
ORE RECENT
E R INVESTIGATION
BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
OV BROAD NUMBEAN WHAT E SPECIAL
ISE IS LOOKING AT THE  THER PRE
INSES
ELECTIONS O OVN RESULTS UPNCS O
E WHIC AT OF CIVILE THATS GOIN
N EAF N AGAIVING T WITH
FORMER PRESIDENT'S EFFORT TO
DEPRIVE THRIF CITIZENS
G TO OVERTURN THEIR
ELECTIONS, TRY PUSE
IN A NUMBER OF KEY STATE
WAY FOR HIM TOAIN IN P
THAHEL INROUGH THIS.
FAIRLY LENGTHY .T POPPED U THE
SYSTEM JUST NOW.
ANSO NOW GOING TO GO TO
D ALLEGATI W
INVESTIGATION MOREN
S OLG FOUND AS
RESULT OF TH, JAKE.
>> ALLHT.
TUO YOURO PAULA REID ABOUT SOME
INTERESTING HERE ON PAGE OF
THE INDICTMENT, IT MENTIONS
DONA
CO-CONIR
E OTHEINS UMABLYBEEN ALERTED AL.
BUT EINOERE IS CCO1
THROUGH
-CATOR 1
YOU, AHO WAS WILLING TO
SPREAD CLAIM
D S
DEFENDANT' RRNS Y NUMBER OF VEHH
L.IRATORSTRATEGYLEVERAGE THE
OBSTRUCT THEER
THE PRESIDENTIALLE
T CENL
EAMA
CO-CONSPAT, ATTORNEY OF
OF ELECTION
ANY
ACKNOWLEDGED TO OVERS SOUNDED
JUSTICE DEPART WKED ONVIL MATTA
DEPARTME TO
INVESTOWINGLY
FALSE CLAIMS OF RAUD
WHO DO YOU SUSPECT THAT IS?
>> IOU EXPECT, BUT I
THAT WAS WHO WAS IN
NMENTAS T UP FROM THE DEPTHS OF
E DEPARTMENT BAU
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS ALLIE
THOUT LD BE ABLEPU
THLLERTURNELECTIONS, ONLY IN
BATATES,SE.
ORWHDEVISING TO
IMPLEMENT ANO SUBMIT
FRAUDULENT SLATEOF
PRESIDENTIALLE
OBSTRUCT THETI
SO THAT IS SOMEBODREPRESUMABLY.
>> YEAH, TSE
'RA AS MS.
FIRST
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
BEEN WONDERING IF TH
PRESIDENT WOULD  ONLY ONE
I WAS QUITE SURPD SPNI'S LR IME
MONTH SINCE HEAS BEEN
INTERVD AND HE
RUDY GIULIAND NOT BE
CHARGED.
ASDERSTAND BASED ON LE
A
APPEA BASED ON THIS
MENTIONED AS ONSPIRATOR, BUT H
BEORCHARGED.
INSTEADF INDICTING
SEVEN FFT HAVE CHARG
SEVERAL OF WHTHE PROMINENT FOL.
AND THERE WETH 'T CLEAR IF THEI.
RUDYIUN EAMA
SOMEONE WE DID EXPECT WOULD BE
GED.Y IDNEY POWELL
LISTE DESCRIBED
ERY SIMILARLY TO
>> CO-CONSPIRATOR 1 OUR ES R IH
T  CHARGED WITH ANYTHING, T
E NOT BEING CHARGED WITH
TH PRESIDENT, JAKE THA YETE IND.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
NLY IN OUR REPORTING, WE
WEREREEE W  T.
A EXPECTING TO HEAR IN THE DEP
AVE M ISSUS SOMETHING WE DON'T Y
QUESTIONS.
T IN PUTS THE FACE
OF SOMEONE FROM THE JUIC
DEPARTMENT WHO I SPEAK
HEMEN PUBLIC AND
AIN THIS
EXTRAORDINARY ACTION, WHTONDE F
THI
I'LL DRAW YOURTTENTION T OERE IT
LOOKS AT THER PRESIDENT'S
STD,ATE THINGS THAT
OBVIOUFOWE'VE
BEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPA BRI
CASE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP, THE
FALSE. THEY SAHERE INDANT
COSPTHEIR ALE D EN OUTCOME
DETERMINATIVE FRAUIN0
D, .D THEYPR
INCLUDINZE THAERD BEENBSTANTIALN
O ONO  ALL
OF WAYS THAT THEY
WERE TG E THERPENCE.
THEYTHE EFFORT
OBVIOUSLY TOET TRS.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS IC TO AUD
JUCOMES INTO.E TR
THERE WAS OUORS, STATE
TO DG RESU TO SEATAKE
ELECTS OR THE.
ALL OFHI BEIP